welcome back Israeli forces are on the
ground in Gaza right now the IDF has
been hammering Gaza for hours and a key
adviser to prime minister yeyahu and
they are not going to stop until Hamas
is eliminated Hamas is feeling now
Israel's might they will continue to be
on the receiving end of our military
blows until we have dismantled their
military machine and and dissolve their
political structure in Gaza when this is
Gaza will be very different thank you
Mike Tobin is in southern Israel with an
update
Mike well Jesse the sky here continues
to rumble and pop as air strikes go into
the Gaza Strip and the artillery is
firing in support of the troops that are
on the ground in the Gaza Strip now for
the past three nights we have seen
Israeli incursions into the land of the
Gaza Strip uh land around the Gaza Strip
but they come out uh what we are seeing
tonight at at least as described by rear
Admiral Daniel hagari is an expansion of
the ground incursions we have seen to
this point uh we know that some of the
armor has rolled into Gaza and we've got
reports that uh uh that Hamas Fighters
have made contact with some of that uh
uh some of that armor that has gone in
by contact I mean they're trying to
fight uh the Israeli forces as they're
advancing into the Gaza Strip as far as
conditions in Gaza what the information
I'm getting is that the whole of Gaza
City was subject to uh to air strikes
today uh the power is out uh mostly
because of the loss of fuel and the
internet service and cell service has
gone out in the Gaza Strip there's one
guy I'm keeping in contact with uh
because he's got an American phone and
apparently it's pinging off an Israeli
Tower but communication is very
difficult the world food Pro food
program says they've lost contact with
uh with their staff and um and that
really is the situation we're waiting to
see how uh how things sort out tonight
uh but again if people who were watching
uh all of us were watching anticipating
a uh full froed invasion of the Gaza
Strip and what we're hearing from the
IDF is this is not that but as uh we've
heard from the assistant to adviser to
the Prime Minister that uh this is the
start of Hamas getting payback for what
they did on October 7th Jesse thanks
Mike stay safe The increased operation
comes as us fighter jets carry out air
strikes against Iranian link sites in
Syria following more than a dozen drone
and Rocket attacks against American
forces there and in Iraq we're just
learning of a 20th attack on US troops
in the Middle East since October 17th
and the Pentagon says they're ready to
strike those Terror groups again we'll
see we'll see if uh Iran gets the
message uh but you know as we've done in
the past uh we certainly reserve the
right to take uh additional strikes and
and continue to ensure that the message
is loud and clear that we will protect
our forces and that these kinds of
attacks are unacceptable these strikes
were very much done in self-defense as
you know our our forces and facilities
had come under a range of attacks rocket
attacks largely by these proxy groups
but that are backed by Iran uh in Iraq
and in Syria all right will before we
get to the Israeli ground incursion in a
second so we struck a few targets and
that didn't apparently get the message
through we're getting return fire what
does that tell
you it tells you that these Iranian back
terrorist groups are not that concerned
about the reaction of the United States
now I will tell you that I I feel for
the administration or anybody trying to
thread this needle in that how do you
avoid a World War and then how do you
back the bully down and that's a tough
needle to thread but you have to only
the only answer I think we've ever
learned throughout history is that you
have to respond with strength and I
think you can accomplish both goals
hopefully without provoking an
overwhelming Regional war and one that
spills over to us um but while backing
down these minor attacks against
Americans which deserve a response and a
response of strength and this new
incursion into Northern Gaza to me it
looks like a shaping operation you know
you go in you probe you see what the
Hamas reaction is what the tactics are
what the intelligence tells you and then
that kind of leads you to the next step
into a formal ground Invasion how do you
interpret what's going on well we were
talking about this a little bit earlier
um Trey yank's laid out for us the
Israeli Army's main goals here as they
prepare for this ground Invasion the top
two goals of which were one destroy
Hamas two recover hostages and I was
just in the process of saying I think
those two goals are very hard to
accomplish together David biva earned
the Medal of Honor on my show the will
Kane podcast was describing Urban
Warfare infantry he won he earned excuse
me he earned the Medal of Honor for
fujia and he talks about studying Berlin
and studying Gras and he said the bottom
line is when you send the Infantry in
it's no longer a scalpel operation now
there may be Special Forces out there
that are capable of bringing back
hostages but once you send in the
Infantry once you roll in it's about
taking out the enemy it's a brute lethal
Force anything else in there is a
secondary goal and it's going to be a
methodical operation that could take
months where hearing Sandra uh General
Kellogg made that prediction on our air
earlier when I asked him uh to predict
just that the rear Admiral Daniel hagari
we all saw him on camera earlier he was
talking the Army spokesman uh he said
that these aerial attacks have been
targeting M tunnels and other Targets in
addition to the taxs we carried out in
recent days he said ground forces are
expanding their activity right now the
IDF is acting with great force he
detailed to achieve the objectives of
this War I think we have to start to ask
ourselves what the endgame is and what
victory is and and what that will look
like Israel said its plan is to crush
hamas's rule in Gaza and its ability to
threaten Israel we know that as clear
but how hamas's defeat will be measured
and the invasion's end end game I think
Jesse you can make the case remains
unclear at this hour so as those days
hours days and weeks go on that is going
to be a bigger and bigger question yeah
it's as we said it is surgical from the
air but once you get in there and you
have
tunnels we actually got a report that
they're throwing in the bunker Busters
so this is going to be a gnarly scene in
a couple weeks could be I think will is
everybody agree with I think Will's
point about trying to balance and
understand how do you thread the needle
here when you have to do two things
first uh you have to destroy hosis
capabilities I think Sandra your point
about how does that look what is the
definition of that and I think the
Israelis are going to Define that
because they're the ones that have to
live with the consequence or the answer
to that question and I my hunch is I'm
53 years old I sered in Congress 27
years ago I didn't think we would see
this moment but I I sense a resoluteness
and determination on the part of the
Israelis to never have a generation of
Israelis have to deal with this again on
their borders so I think they will they
will answer that question decisively I
think the second part of to Will's point
about how do you balances and thread the
needle is how do we keep our Arab allies
where there's massive conversation
coordination to the extent there can be
right now uh on our side because I think
those allies including European allies
but particularly those in the Arab
region uh we have to keep them as aign
with us as possible as we respond to
some of these attacks and as we get
proactive about attacking to ensure that
not they're not able to attack our
troops and our assets one thing is clear
we talked a few weeks ago on the show we
talked about how the president may not
have been mentioning the Iranians by
name they know dogon well that he knows
who they are where they are uh and we
have the greatest not only intelligence
service but military on the ground more
assets than we've ever had in that
region in my lifetime since War uh since
wartime and we're going to have even
more come next week so um I I I give
them the benefit of the doubt on this
more than perhaps some might uh but I
got to tell you uh if we don't respond
with Force as will said this will
continue and I think you've said it each
night on your show as well so I I I I
God bless the president and God bless
our troops as they go about exercising
and litigating the toughest thing that
I've seen in my lifetime judge did you
find these counter strikes by the US
military to be a little too tentative
perhaps a little too late well I think
that we heard this past week that they
were waiting for the missile defense
systems to get over those particular
countries I think it was Saudi Arabia
Kuwait
you know so that we at least were in a
position to defend our troops now I've
heard now that there have been 20
attacks on our air on our troops but we
don't know yet how many troops have been
injured they haven't told us that and it
took them a long time to tell us that we
there were 13 attacks now unfortunately
I disagree with one thing that Harold
said you know we don't have the best
intelligence our intelligence failed us
on this we have 33 Americans who were
killed we've got at least 13 over there
that are in the tunnel right now and let
me say one thing This is war war is ugly
Jesse you use the word gnarly the truth
is Hamas headquarters are located under
a hospital and you're not supposed to
attack a hospital unless they're using
the enemy uses a hospital to protect
itself and it can't do that and the
question of pro proportionality must be
consistent with a military goals and a
legitimate Target the owners right now
is on Hamas Hamas by putting their
Pentagon under a hospital has just
committed a war crime and there is no
question they spent two years preparing
this they have been working with
landlines so nobody could access the
information they had it's only with
human intelligence and human sourcing
that we know where these tunnels are
there are over 400 miles of tunnels
underground we have no idea where are
americ Americans are and so what we've
got to do is recognize that there will
be harm that there will be damage and
that the only time Israel will stop and
this is their war is when they get rid
of Hamas and I think BB just stated uh
in Israel that tonight is the turning
point tonight is the war tonight is when
they take down Hamas and uh unless we
join them in making sure that this
happens in a way where this kind of
thing never happens again then you know
we're going to be subjected to these
kinds of attacks as well let me just
respond one second when I said judge
when I said about our intelligence all
they have to do is be right one time and
they were right one time there were
things that were ignored at least some
of the press reports we're seeing there
were things that we and Israelis ignored
or didn't take as serious as we should
have over the last several weeks I think
that our intelligence is the best in the
world but we didn't catch this of course
we didn't otherwise we wouldn't be
having this conversation my only point
is they have to only be right once and
they were right once this they were
right this time we are now but Jud I'm
an American and I believe when our when
our forces and our intelligence say that
they are on the ground and are focused
on this the way that we believe they are
whether we agree with their politics or
not I know you agree with I just don't I
I just what are you saying I'm agreeing
too that when we've got American forces
on the ground it's the best what are you
saying what are you differing with they
missed this MI6 missed it the Mad missed
it shinette missed it everybody missed
this they had signs and they ignored
those signs and they won't I don't
believe they'll ignore these signs to
agree we agree one more thing's up next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else